[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und dunia
Hayali schönen guten Abend Israels
Premierminister steht unter Druck aus
mehreren Gründen zum einen wird die
humanitäre Lage im gaserstreifen im
katastrophaler was international
kritisiert wird genauso wie der
entwürdigende Umgang mit
palästinensischen Gefangenen zum anderen
wächst aber auch der Zweifel dass das
israelische Militär den wie Netanyahu es
nennt totalen Sieg erringen kann
geschweige denn ein Plan für das danach
hat doch den größten jedenfalls inneren
Druck dürften die Angehörigen erzeugen
deren Priorität weiterhin die
Freilassung der Geiseln ist insbesondere
nachdem vorgestern ja drei Geiseln
versehentlich von israelischen Soldaten
erschossen wurden Netanyahu braucht also
dringend Erfolge und die hat er heute
präsentieren lassen Henriette de
Mia drei Männer können aufrecht
nebeneinander in diesem Tunnel gehen
Bilder die das israelische Militär heute
veröffentlicht sie haben einen Tunnel
riesigen Ausmaßes der Hamas entdeckt 50
m tief 4 km lang es ist der größte den
die Israel Arme entdeckt hat er endet
nur kurz vor dem israelischen
Grenzübergang
eres dieser Tunnel endet nur 400 m vor
dem Grenzübergang ires ein Übergang der
immer ein Symbol der Hoffnung war für
viele Palästinenser tausende ging jeden
Tag hier durch zu ihrer Arbeit nach
Israel der Tunnel hingegen so der
Armeesprecher heute sei für Anschläge
auf Israel gebaut worden das ist Hamas
sie steht für Terror wir müssen sie
besiegen
es soll einen Erfolg zeigen denn der
Premierminister kommt unter Druck vor
allem nach der versehentlichen Tötung
von drei Geiseln durch israelische
Soldaten netanahu muss sich erklären und
bleibt doch bei alten
Floskel wir werden bis zum Ende kämpfen
und unsere Ziele erreichen die Hamas
eliminieren alle unsere Geiseln befreien
und sicherstellen dass Gaza nicht wieder
zum Zentrum des Terrors und der Hetze
gegen den Staat Israel wird sie rufen
uns rennt die Zeit davon bringt die
Geiseln zurück Angehörige der entführten
Lagern seit gestern direkt vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium in Tel
Aviv wir werden hier bleiben bis die
Regierungsmitglieder kommen uns in die
Augen schauen und einen Plan
präsentieren wir müssen die Geiseln so
schnell wie möglich befreien denn an
jedem Tag der vergeht wird die Chance
kleiner dass mein Bruder lebend
zurückkommt im Gazastreifen gehen heute
die israelischen Angriffe am Boden und
aus der Luft und verändert weiter
Krankenhäuser wie hier in chones sind
längst schon am Limit verletzte werden
auf dem Boden versorgt selbst der Weg
hierher
gefährlich nirgends ist es sicher aber
ich musste das riskieren und hierher
kommen ich habe Angst auch hier getötet
zu werden wir sind überall in Gefahr
auch heute kamen wieder Hilfsgüter über
die Grenze nach Gaza doch sie kommen
nicht bei allen an bewaffnete Männer
kontrollieren bei RAA der Ladung auf
andere LKW stürzen sich Dutzende
Menschen die diese Hilfe so dringend
brauchen der Chef des israelischen
Geheimdienstes mossat soll mit dem
katarischen Ministerpräsidenten
zusammengekommen sein um über Geiseln
und Feuerpause zu verhandeln fragen wir
nach bei Henriette dem misär in Tel Aviv
Henriette was hörst du denn über diese
Verhandlung Qatar bemüht sich na Angaben
um Vermittlung zwischen den
Kriegsparteien laut Medienberichten
treffen sich in Norwegen diplomatische
und Diplomaten aus Qatar
Vertreter bestätigt W haben wir diese
Nachricht bisher nicht bekommen was wir
wissen ist Qatar hat schon einmal
vermittelt zusammen mit Ägypten im
November wurde ein sogenannter Deal
ausgehandelt ind dem Geiseln aus der von
der Hamas freigelassen wurden im
Austausch gegen Häftlinge aus
israelischen Gefängnissen Qatar ist im
Gespräch mit der Hamas das wissen wir
insofern könnten Sie ein guter
Vermittler sein das Treffen also
möglicherweise an einem historischen Ort
übrigens in Oslo vor 30 Jahren
verständigten sicher Israelis und
Palästinenser auf konkrete Schritte zum
Frieden und einer zwei
staatenlösung denkt im Moment
irgendjemand an solche
Schritte für viele hier in Israel ist
klar nach dem 7 Oktober
2023 wird nichts mehr sein wie es einmal
war der israelische Präsident Herzog hat
am Freitag noch mal bekräftigt um über
eine zweist staatenlösung nachzudenken
sei es noch viel zu früh der Schmerz
sitze noch zu tief Benjamin netanyah
sagt immer wieder wie du es auch in der
Anmoderation gesagt hat er werde kämpfen
bis zum totalen Sieg und die Hamas sagt
solange nicht eine Feuerpause und die
Waffen schweigen werden sie nicht
verhandeln es sieht also nicht gut aus
für ein friedliches Ende in baldiger
Zeit Einschätzungen von Henriette
demesia vielen Dank dafür nach Tel
Aviv ja und der Krieg zwischen Israel
und der Hamas hat ja auch das Leben hier
in Deutschland verändert im Großen wie
im Kleinen an Universitäten so wie hier
an der FU Berlin kam es und kommt es
immer wieder zu Auseinandersetzungen bei
einer hörsam Besetzung sollen
proalästinensische Aktivisten jüdischen
Studierenden den Eintritt in einen
hörsal verweigert haben die Polizei
musste eingreifen am Donnerstag wurden
in Berlin drei mutmaßliche
hamasmitglieder verhaftet der Verdacht
sie hätten Anschläge auf jüdische
Einrichtungen in Deutschland
geplant und darüber möchte ich jetzt mit
Stefan Kramer sprechen sie waren 10
Jahre lang Generalsekretär des
Zentralrats der junen in Deutschland und
sind seit
2015 Präsident des Verfassungsschutzes
in Thüringen schönen guten Abend an sie
guten Abend aus Erfurt Herr Krammer über
die laufenden Ermittlungen da sagen Sie
ganz sicher nichts aber ein erneuter
Versuch eventuell sogar ein
erfolgreicher Anschlag wie hoch ist die
Gefahr die Gefahr ist sehr hoch
extrem hoch Kollege haldenwagen vom BFV
hat ja auch schon letzte Woche dazu
ausgeführt wir haben eine extrem hohe
Gefahr durch äh islamistischen
Terrorismus in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland besonders nach dem 7 oktober
also wenn ich sie richtig verstehe ist
dann Deutschland nicht mehr nur
Rückzugsraum für hamaskämpfer sondern
nun auch Aktionsraum das ist richtig
davon müssen wir ausgehen insbesondere
weil in den Aufrufen auch zum weltweiten
Jihad nicht nur Jüdinnen und Juden
betroffen sind sondern auch die
kreuzzykler also die Unterstützer
Nationen und Bevölkerungen und ins
besondere seitdem es uns gelungen ist
erfolgreich in einigen Bundesländern
konkrete Anschlagspläne auch zu
verhindern wenn es um Antisemitismus
geht da hatte der Verfassungsschutz
bisher ja insbesondere eher die neue
Rechte im Visier haben sie beim
islamistischen der ja jetzt nicht von
heute auf morgen entstanden ist
eventuell dann was übersehen nein wir
haben im Bereich des ist des
antisemitismuses wie auch in allen
anderen Bereichen die uns beschäftigen
in 260° Bick das heißt wir wissen seit
langem dass es Antisemitismus aus allen
Bereichen des politischen oder auch
religiösen Extremismus gibt und es ist
uns nie verborgen geblieben dass
insbesondere auch im Islamismus
Antisemitismus zur DNA dazu gehört noch
mal erschwerend durch den Zuzug von
Flüchtlingen und Menschen aus arabischen
Ländern in denen Antisemitismus zur DNA
gehört äh haben wir verstärkt mit diesem
Phänomen zu tun und setz uns damit
auseinander also neben dem importierten
auch dem eimheimischen Antisemitismus
über die wie Sie es nennen DNA will ich
gleich noch mal sprechen aber noch mal
kurzer Blick auf diesen
360° Bick wie Sie es nennen also
antisemitische Ausschreitungen bei denen
terroristische Gewalt verherrlicht wurde
die gab es ja schon vor dem
hamasüberfall am 7 Oktober z.B im April
in Berlin viel passiert ist dann da aber
nicht und das obwohl beispielsweise die
Hamas seit 2001 auf der EU Terror Liste
steht jetzt nach dem 7.10 gab es Verbote
sogar angekündigte Verbote Stichwort
Netzwerk samidon ist das nicht alles zu
spät sicherlich ist es spät ähm ich
selber habe ja auch deutlich gemacht
dass ich mich schon lange darüber
gewundert habe warum hier nicht schon
früher auch in anderen Bundesregierungen
konkrete Maßnahmen umgesetzt worden sind
sie haben es ja gerade schon gesagt äh
die Organisationen sind zum Teil seit
vielen vielen Jahren bereits auf
Terrorlisten und auch unter der
Beobachtung des des Verfassungsschutzes
und der Sicherheitsbehörden ich habe
Verständnis dafür dass man nach dem 7
Oktober dann noch mal ein deutliches
politisches Signal setzen wollte aber im
Grunde genommen hätte man schon viel
früher einschreiten müssen denn diese
Strukturen wachsen natürlich richtig ist
aber W hat sie denn gehindert
äh uns in Thüringen ich bin mit Verlaub
nur der Verfassungsschutzpräsident ist
im Land Thüringen wir in den
Sicherheitsbehörden haben schon sehr
früh auf die Gefährdung aufmerksam
gemacht aber es ist nicht unsere Aufgabe
exekutivmaßnahmen einzuleiten und
umzusetzen dafür ist die Politik
verantwortlich Herr kamer
gruppenverbieten das mag jetzt ein Weg
sein um Antisemitismus oder Terrorismus
zu bekämpfen Bildung wäre ein anderer
oder wie manche ja jetzt fordern
wiederfordern geflüchtete nicht mehr ins
Land lassen Stichwort ist da der
importierte Antisemitismus gehen sie
damit weil sie ja auch gerade von der
DNA Sprachen also ich GLB hier müssen
wir zwei Dinge auseinanderhalten wenn es
darum geht Flüchtlingen Schutzräume zu
bieten vor Verfolgung äh in ihren
Heimatländern äh in dem im Ausland dann
ist das glaube ich eine ehrenvolle
Verpflichtung die wir auch aufgrund
unseres Grundgesetzes umsetzen und
unsere Erfahrungen äh wie man dann
allerdings mit den Menschen umgeht die
hierherkmen und die nichts anderes
gelernt haben das spielt sicherlich
Bildung und auch Unterweisung eine ganz
große Rolle die hat es in den
vergangenen Jahren nur marginal gegeben
und deswegen kämpfen wir auch mit einem
verhärteten Antisemitismus in diesem
Bereich äh grundsätzlich ist es aber so
äh dass eben der Antisemitismus auch zur
DNA des Islamismus gehört und deswegen
ist für uns immer klar gewesen dass auch
die jüdische Gemeinschaft in der
Bundesrepublik aber auch weltweit in den
jihadistischen Wellen 21 214 und jetzt
223 immer ein besonderes Ziel dieses
wenn Sie so wollen islamistischen
Antisemitismus gewesen aber müsste man
nicht schon auch differenzieren und
jetzt nicht alle Muslime oder Menschen
mit einer Migrationsgeschichte aus dem
arabischen Raum über einem kamschern so
wie es z.B die neue Rechte jetzt auch
wieder versucht
da stimme ich Ihnen völlig zu hier muss
man sehr deutlich unterscheiden weil
wenn Muslime ob geflüchtet oder schon
seit vielen Jahren auch hier im Land
lebend jetzt diskriminiert ausgegrenzt
oder mit dem falschen Vorwurf
grundsätzlich antisemitisch zu sein
konfrontiert werden dann treiben wir sie
im Grunde genommen in die Arme der
Islamisten und das kann nicht unser Ziel
sein abgesehen davon sind die Mehrzahl
der Muslime die hier in Deutschland
leben keine Antisemiten sagt der
Präsident des Verfassungsschutz in
Thüringen vielen herzlichen Dank für
Ihre Zeit heute abend Stefan Krammer
danke Ihnen und das Gespräch haben wir
am frühen Abend aufgezeichnet jetzt
kümmern wir uns mal ums Geld wenn 17
Milliarden eingespart werden müssen und
drei sich darauf verständigen wer in den
sauren Apfel beißen muss dann war
eigentlich klar dass das noch zu Ärger
führen wird und genauso ist es nun
gekommen sauer sind z.B die Landwirte so
sauer sogar dass der FDP Minister nun
doch noch mal darüber nachdenkt ob das
Streichen der
agrardieselsubventionen so eine gute
Idee war die FDP Fraktion im Bundestag
kündigte heute gar ein Veto gegen die
Pläne an all das dürfte dem grünen
Agrarminister gefallen denn der fand das
von vornh rein falsch sauer dürften aber
auch die sein die sich ein E-Auto kaufen
wollten und auf staatliche Zuschüsse
gehofft hatten die fallen weg ziemlich
abprupt und t heißt sofort also heute
Christian von
Rechenberg wer jüngst noch fragte was
ein Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
zum Bundeshaushalt konkret für die
Menschen bedeutet bekam jetzt eine erste
Antwort die Förderung für E-Autos endet
Schlag
Mitternacht aus unserer Sicht kommt es
zu abrupt wir brauchen eine angemessene
Übergangslösung für die Menschen die
darauf vertraut haben dass sie eine
Förderung bekommen und beispielsweise
morgen einen zulassungstermin haben und
dann den Antrag stellen wollten das sagt
nicht die Opposition das Sagen
Abgeordnete der regierenden SPD der
Ampel droht mal wieder Zoff aus dem
eigenen Stall also zu einer Demokratie
gehört dazu dass man Regierung auch
kritisieren darf als Parlamentarier das
tun wir und wir gehen davon aus dass
diese Kritik jetzt auch dazu führt dass
sie wahrgenommen wird und dass eine
angemessene Lösung entwickelt wird denn
e-Autos sind teuer für Menschen mit
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen Bein
Luxus die Förderung sollte die Strom
attraktiver machen 15 million von ihen
sollten gar bis 2030 auf die Straßen zur
Zeit sind es gerade mal 1,3 Millionen
wir haben jetzt einen Einbruch gesehen
bei Elektroautos von über 20% und es
gilt eigentlich jetzt mehr zu fördern
mehr Maßnahmen zu ergreifen um eben
diese ambitionierten Ziele eben auch zu
erreichen in Deutschland und wir werden
hier mit einer Kauf Zurückhaltung
rechnen müssen bei den privatkundinnen
und Kunden woanders wie etwa in
Frankreich ginge die Regierung den genau
umgekehrten Weg aber die förderprämien
noch mal erhöht doch der Ampel fehle
dazu das Geld heißt es aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium man
bedauere Menschen enttäuschen zu müssen
aber die kurzfristige Entscheidung war
notwendig und außerdem Zitat wurde sie
gemeinsam mit dem Bundeskanzleramt
festgelegt die einseitige Kritik dazu
Weise man daher
zurück nicht alle kritischen Stimmen
sehen heute die Politik allein in der
Pflicht blicken auch auf die
Verantwortung der
Hersteller also aus unserer Sicht ist es
mittelfristig richtig E-Autos nicht
dauernd dauerhaft zu fördern weil sie
müssen sich am Markt bewähren und
einfach bezahlbar sein das Modell
Angebot muss sich verbreitern und es
muss mehr Wettbewerb sein ein richtiger
echter Preiswettbewerb und bis der kommt
so der ADAC weiter sei eventuell der
Gebrauchtwagenmarkt für E-Autos eine
interessante und vor allem bezahlbare
[Musik]
Alternative eine andere Alternative wäre
natürlich die Schuldenbremse zu lockern
oder zu verändern aber Heinz da macht
der csuchchef weiterhin nicht mit ja
Markus Söder hat das Nein der
Unionsfraktion zu einer Veränderung der
Schuldenbremse bekräftigt in der
zdfsendung Berlin direkt sagte Söder man
könne nicht in eine Schuldenspirale
einsteigen das wäre ein falsches Signal
dass Deutschland für ganz Europa senden
würde für uns ist ganz klar cdcs im
Deutschen Bundestag werden auf keinen
Fall einer Veränderung der
Schuldenbremse zustimmen damit ist eine
notwendige zwei Drittel Mehrheit für
eine verfassungsänderte Situation nicht
gegeben serbien hat ein neues Parlament
gewählt und nach ersten Hochrechnungen
liegt die rechtsnationale
Fortschrittspartei von Präsident wuc mit
knapp 47% in Führung wuc hatte auf
Rentenerhöhungen und einmal Zahlungen an
Eltern und Oberschüler gesetzt um seine
Partei eine hohe Zustimmung zu sichern
trotz her Inflation Auslöser für die
vorgezogenen Wahlen waren vor allem
monatelange Proteste wegen zwei
Amokläufen im
Mai Russland und die Ukraine haben heute
erneut Drohnenangriffe der jeweils
anderen Seite gemeldet nach ukrainischen
Angaben ist bei den russischen Angriffen
in der Schwarzmeerregion Odessa ein
Mensch getötet worden eine abgeschossene
Drohne sei auf sein Haus gestürzt und
explodiert 20 Drohnen seien insgesamt
abgeschossen
worden erstmals hat ein Kandidat der AFD
eine Oberbürgermeisterwahl in
Deutschland gewonnen der 53-Jährige Tim
Lochner setzte sich heute im sächsischen
Pirner im zweiten Wahlgang laut dem
vorläufigen Endergebnis mit rund
38,5% der Stimmen durch Lochner ist
parteilos trat aber für die AFD
an vier Jahre nach dem Brand von
notreddam hat die Kathedrale in Paris
wieder eine Wetterfahne die goldene Hahn
wurde per Kran an seinen Platz gebracht
im Inneren befinden sich Reliquien und
eine Liste mit den Namen von rund 2000
Menschen die am Wiederaufbau der Kirche
beteiligt waren notreadam soll in einem
Jahr dann wieder eröffnet
werden crime as a lifestyle Kriminalität
als Lebensentwurf das scheint ein neues
bandenphänomen zu sein nicht aber etwa
in Paris New York oder Stockholm sondern
hier bei uns in Stuttgart die jungen
Männer meist bildungsfern multiethnisch
und mit Migrationshintergrund ein der
Nervenkitzel und wohlmöglich auch die
Suche nach Zugehörigkeit nach Identität
und die mündet aktuell in Schießereien
Brandstiftung und Sachbeschädigung und
sogar Bedrohungen die
eskalationsschraube kennt da kein Ende
und die Polizei schaut nicht tatenlos zu
Eva schiller hat sie bei ihrem Katz und
Mausspiel
begleitet schwarz vermummt marschieren
sie durch Stuttgarts Straßen skandieren
Rache jeder Tat folgt die
Vergeltung die Polizei in Stuttgart will
aufmerksam machen auf ein neues
bandenphänomen auf junge Männer die das
Verbrechen verbindet sie zeigen mir wie
sich kürzlich eine Bande mitten in der
Innenstadt formiert sie tritt recht
schnell marzianisch auf die Leute
drumrum sind ein bisschen verunsichert
was soll sie machen wie soll sich
bewegen e so eine Machtdemonstration
schon macht und territorialdemonstration
genau was mit aufmärchen begann vor
eineinhalb Jahren eskaliert in einem
Krieg Banden fast 20 Schießereien
mehrere Tote und Verletzte dramatischer
Höhepunkt ein Bandenmitglied wirft im
Juni eine Handgranate auf Trauernde
dieser Baum verhindert ein blutbart
anders als in Berlin oder Köln ein die
jungen Männer kein kan keine
Nationalität sondern der Nervenkitzel
wir bezeichnen das so ein bisschen dass
ist so Kriminalität als Lebensentwurf
crime a lifestyle also die Männer 18 bis
28 Jahre
multiethnisch wir können feststelle dass
fast alle Migrationshintergrund haben
die meisten kommen so aus Bildung
bildungsfernen milies rund 500 junge
Männer umfasst allein der Kern der
Banden ihr Vorbild ihr Kid Rapper wie SK
und das sind schon Leute die zu diesen
Gruppen gehören und die Sage zum Teil in
den Texten wir sind kriminell do es geht
uns nicht nach um Gewinn sondern und da
kommt immer Ehre und Respekt und solche
Dinge ne ich weiß nicht wie dubst meine
Mannschaft Blut was die Rapper singen
übertragen ihre Supporter offenbar auf
die Straße ich fahre nach Esslingen
Revier der zweiten Bande obwohl sich
hier der Stern eines mercedeswerks dreht
ist das Viertel sozial abgehängt 2022
war das der erste Schauplatz des
straßenkriegs 19 Schüsse fielen Mustafa
bagi ist hier aufgewachsen aber
mittlerweile weggezogen erkennt die Hut
wenn jetzt so ein Jugendlicher in so
einer Bande mitmcht dann bekommt ja die
Möglichkeit ein tolles Auto zu fahren
wenn es auch nicht seins ist und wenn er
ehrlich arbeitet lebt er normales Leben
und in diesem Instagram Zeitalter wo ja
jeder pralt damit was für ein tolles
Leben er sie
führt ja da da da weckt es eben die
Begierde der Jugendlichen um
Verhältnisse wie in Stockholm oder
Marseille zu verhindern fordert die
Polizei mehr Personal sie haben
mittlerweile 52 Männer festgenommen die
Banden wachsen weiter da ist diese
Sogwirkung auch auf Einwanderer das
macht natürlich Sorge was ist mit denen
die jetzt gerade kommen wir integrieren
sie sich die nächsten Jahre hoffentlich
nicht in diese Gruppierungen rein wie
leicht das passiert zeigt der laufende
Prozess gegen das Bandenmitglied dass
die Handgranate geworfen hat der Iraner
ist 2016 nach Deutschland geflüchtet die
Ermittler gehen davon aus dass die Tat
eine Mutprobe war um in der
bandenhierarchie aufzusteigen der
Angeklagte schweigt wie alle bislang
ehren Kodex der
Banden und die ganze Reportage zum
eskalierenden Bandenkrieg in Stuttgart
finden Sie unter
zdfheute.de und hier rollt jetzt der
Ball rüber zu Heinz für den Sport an
diesem Sonntag zuerst zur Fußball
buundesliga heute mit drei Spielen und
diesen Ergebnissen tabellenspitzenreiter
Bayern Leverkusen gewinnt gegen
Eintracht Frankfurt 3:0 der Tabellen
zweite Bayern München gegen den VfB
Stuttgart ebenfalls 3:0 und der SC
Freiburg gegen den ersten fC Köln
2:0 bei den Skispringern heute Tag 2 in
Engelberg und Pius Paschke landete
wieder weit vorne nach seinem ersten
Weltcupsieg gestern heute Platz 3 Jubel
bei skiespringer Pius Paschke wieder in
Engelberg auf dem Podium die Form ist
einfach sicher gerade so gut wie no nie
und ja die Mischung macht dann war Hal
wieder wirklich cooler Wettkampfes
zweiter Sprung von der Tit schanceze
bringt den 33-Jährigen auf Rang 3 nicht
zu bezwingen heute in der Schweiz aber
der führende im Gesamtweltcup Stefan
Kraft holt mit einer Weite von 142 m
seinen fünft Saisonsieg vor einem
weiteren Österreicher Jan Hörl in einem
starken deutschen Team wird Karl Geiger
vierter Andreas Wellinger landet auf
Rang
5 und beim Ski Langlauf Weltcup im
norwegischen troneim sorgte Victoria
Karl für eine große Überraschung beim
intervallstart über 10 km klassisch
stürmte die 28-Jährige mit 19,6 Sekunden
Vorsprung als schnellste ins Ziel Karls
Weg an die Weltspitze hat damit einen
vorläufigen Höhepunkt genommen der
nächste soll dann schon über den
Jahreswechsel bei der tourdei
gelingen Kultur sei Lebenselixir
mobilisiere provoziere kritisiere und
gebe Kraft es sei der Sound unserer
Demokratie das sagte vor kurzem
kulturstaatsministerin rot Worte die
wunderbar klingen und die wohl auch die
meisten ja von uns unterschreiben würden
doch wenn es eng wird also hier
finanziell eng da muss halt gespart
werden noch sieht der Haushalt in dem
Bereich wohl keine Kürzungen vor aber
nicht wenige Theater und Museen kämpfen
ja schon jetzt ums Überleben selbst
solche die man quasi als deutsches
Kulturgut bezeichnen möchte chris hat
lepple Reinsberg ein sehensuchsort als
der Alte Fritz jung war verbrachte er
hier seine besten Jahre und der
22-Jährige Kurt hucholski verfasste hier
sein Bilderbuch für Verliebte das machte
ihn auf Einschlag berühmt und Reinsberg
in aller Welt bekannt seit der Wende
pilerten 1,2 Millionen Menschen in das
tucholzk
Museum wo gibt's in Deutschland in die
so einer kleinen Kommode so einen Ort wo
die Kultur eigentlich maßgeblich den
Wirtschaftsstandort bestimmt das
Reinsberger tholz Literaturmuseum ist in
großer Gefahr sparen heißt es wie
überall im Lande
241000 € fehlen pro Jahr das kleine
Reinsberg mit seinen 8000 Einwohnern ist
klamm da passt es dass der langjährige
Leiter demnächst in Ruhestand geht die
stad beschließt mit knapper Mehrheit
seine Stelle einzusparen ein
tourismusfachmann soll den Gedächtnisort
von nationaler Bedeutung übernehmen
bundeskulturstaatsministerin rot und der
Deutsche Kulturrat schlagen Alarm
die Leitung geht irgendwann in Rente ja
und dann kommt die Politik auf die Idee
und sagt ist do eine tolle Chance und
das versucht man jetzt umzusetzen und
letztendlich bedeutet das nichts anderes
damit ist das Museum tot seit Wochen
streitet das brandenburgische Reinsberg
um sein tuchholzgemuseum der
Bürgermeister von den Freien wähern will
lieber Feuerwehr und Schulen finanzieren
auf einer bürgervversammlung zeigen sich
offen die
Konflikte niemand hat sich diese
Entscheidung gleich getan und sie haben
auch angedeutet
niemand wollte das kaputt machen das
Museum es war ein reiner Sparzwang wir
reden immer über Kultur die irgendwo
eingespart wird ja irgendwo hat man
immer wieder das Thema es ist zu wenig
Geld da es ist zu wenig Geld da jetzt
hat es hier einmal massiv zugeschlagen
Reinsberg ist kein Einzelfall in der
Kultur regiert der Rotstift Museen und
Theater sind bedroht in Lüneburg Erfurt
oder kon
die Frage steht was können wir uns
künftig noch
leisten all das was in Sonntagsreden
seit Jahren behauptet wird nämlich dass
die Kultur was wichtiges ist dass wir
sie brauchen dass sie ein Ort der
gesellschaftlichen Verständigung ist
dass sich das auch übersetzt wenn es
darum geht wofür werden knapper werden
staatliche Ressourcen ausgegeben und ich
kann allen nur sagen ein Haushalt
konsolidiert man nicht indem man an der
Kultur spart wenn wir das wegsparen dann
sparen wir uns die Zukunft Weg das
tucholski Museum könnte gerettet werden
der zuständige Landkreis wird wohl
helfen jetzt muss morgen nur noch die
Stadt reheinsberg
zustimmen
kurcholski sagte mal Geld will ernst
genommen werden sonst kommt es nicht zu
Dir mal schauen wie ernst die Stadt das
ganze morgen nimmt und morgen ist auch
ein gutes Stichwort denn hier kommt
jetzt der Ausblick auf die kommende
Woche von Kai Felix
[Musik]
Jochens am Montag wird das Ergebnis der
Präsidentschaftswahl in Ägypten
offiziell verkündet ein Sieg des
amtierenden Präsidenten als S gilt als
sicher CISS putschte sich vor 10 Jahren
an die Macht und regiert das Land
seither mit harter Hand eine ernsthafte
Opposition gibt es nicht mehr erst die
Änderung der Verfassung machte es
möglich dass alsissi überhaupt für eine
dritte Amtszeit kandidieren konnte am
Donnerstag wird das Urteil des
Europäischen Gerichtshofs zur
fußballsleague erwartet ursprünglich
wollten 12 europäische Topclubs eine
eigene Liga Gründen die
fußballspitzenverbände UEFA und FIFA
Werten sich dagegen drohten den Vereinen
mit Ausschluss aus ihren Wettbewerben
etwa der Champions League der FC
Barcelona und Real Madrid klagten der
EGH
entscheidet und dann ist Weihnachten um
das Fest im Kreise der Familie
verbringen zu können werden wieder
Millionen Menschen quer durchs Land
reisen auf den Schienen über die
Autobahnen in Richtung Besinnlichkeit ob
es gelingt wer weiß jedenfalls täte wohl
uns allen nach diesem nachrichtenjahr
2023 ein ruhiges friedliches
Weihnachtsfest besonders
[Musik]
gut und jetzt die Wetteraussichten zum
Start in den neue Woche von sonnig bis
stürmisch morgen in der Mitte und im
Süden teils sonnig teils neblig im
Norden viele Wolken und zeitweise Regen
an den Küsten stürmischer Südwestwind 4
bis 12° und in den nächsten Tagen kommt
breitet Regen auf es wird noch windiger
bis hin zu schwerem Sturm am Donnerstag
bei 3 bis 11° bestes Wetter um einfach
weiter Fernsehen zu gucken vielleicht ja
auch direkt jetzt denn es folgt die Gala
Sportler Sportlerin des Jahres und
natürlich wird auch die beste Mannschaft
gekürt und die nächste heute Express
gibt's dann gegen 0:30 Uhr wir sehen uns
dann hier morgen wieder um
21:45 Uhr machen sie es gut W immer sie
sind
wiedersehen
ه